the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
the equivalent cost of manufacture in
China right now as best as we can
determine is in the order of $1 dollar
$3 five somewhere in that range with the
arrow bars so keep those numbers in your
head as we dive into price because now
we're going to be talking about what the
market is offering to pay and and what
that spread is between the costs in the
price so you have in your slide deck a
list of different websites I guess you
have web e sits you have websites email
uh serves and blogs and Twitter feeds
different sources of information for
collecting data from PV and I should add
one more to this list which wasn't on
there but should be there PB insights
com this is where you can find a pretty
up-to-date spot prices for wafers cells
modules and so forth does anybody know
what a spot price is what does it mean a
spot price spot price means I'm
desperate to buy I need to buy it right
now I pick up a phone and call somebody
and say I'm willing to pay you so
there's no long-term contract involved
it's usually a one-time deal that's the
spot price a long-term contract in the
other hand says no no really I have a
factory it's 100 megawatts and I need
wafer supply for five years
let's lock lock ourselves into a price
maybe revisited every two and a half
years but but that's a long-term
contract so these are spot prices and
they provide a very a variety of
information the information for today is
free if you want historical data you
have to sign up become a member and pay
but there are other websites like this
various consulting groups that acquire
and gather information pb insights so
you have a variety of different sites to
grab information could be useful for
your class projects we're going to talk
again about the dynamics of price and
that is driven in large part by well we
agreed to call it different things
support mechanisms tax breaks incentives
but in reality they're their support for
PV recognizing that with a dollar thirty
dollar 10 cost and then you add on top
of that the profit margin even if you
assume a very meager
margin of 15% your and then the balance
of systems and then the installation
costs on top of that you're not reaching
grid parity in the majority of markets
not with that sort of cost structure
today with innovation and moving forward
into the future and scale we'll get
there I'm fairly confident but today we
don't have the cost structure necessary
to match say a subsidized coal-fired
power plant so there are a variety of
different support mechanisms variety
from subsidies in different countries
and in different states within the
United States and you can think about
these as the carrot the stick in the
hybrid the carrot meaning the the margin
enhancement the stick being the the
penalty if you produce too much carbon
for instance and some variety of
mixtures between the two so in terms of
margin enhancement the carrot what
mechanisms exist let me break it down
very simply into will look in two
different categories
we'll look at what the United States has
mostly done which are tax relief and
grants in soft loans so let's let's
describe what that means so if I when I
bought the panels on top of the house in
2007 2008 yeah 2007 we paid out of the
box somewhere in the order of seven to
eight dollars per watt-peak
and after tax tax rebate there coming
from the federal government and some
additional support from the state of
Massachusetts the final price tag wound
up being from say 18,000 plus down to
about twelve to fourteen thousand and
then there's revenue coming in from
offsets and so forth so this is a
one-time deal I could have installed
those panels in my basement and still
gotten the tax break right because it's
per watt-peak not per kilowatt hour
produced the rebates based on carbon
emissions is based on the amount of
energy it produces that gives you an
incentive to maximize the efficiency of
the installation but just a one-time tax
rebate doesn't however what the one-time
tax rebate allows you to do is decrease
the upfront sticker price right so if
I'm trying to sell you a system on your
house us installers are convinced that
it's a lot easier to sell you the system
the price tag is lower right if I can
say well this is the real cost but but
wait wait there's more I'll give you
this tax rebate this tax rebate draw a
line the final amount that you pay is
this lower amount right here the other
mechanism of Finance of margin
enhancement if you will is what's called
a feed-in tariff now a feed-in tariff
works as follows a feed-in tariff says
okay if you're paying a say in state of
Massachusetts we don't have one we don't
have a feed-in tariff here in
Massachusetts but imagine if we did you
as a residential customer are paying 18
cents per kilowatt-hour for your
electricity but if you have solar panels
on your roof the utility if you will the
state of Massachusetts is willing to pay
you 30 cents per kilowatt hour for that
PV electricity recognizing the
additional value that that PV is adding
to the state reducing the need for
additional transmission lines reducing
the amount of investment in new
coal-fired power plants reducing the
health detriment to the local
communities around the the coal plant
and so forth so a feed-in tariff is
meant to give an incentive a market pull
incentive if you will to install PV on
your house or in a field and this is the
mechanism that has been in use in
Germany and because it's a market driven
mechanism it rewards the most efficient
systems that are out there if you
install that system in your basement
you're not going to be producing
kilowatt hours and hence you're not
going to benefit from the feed-in
tariffs now it's a tricky business to
decide where exactly to fit that feed-in
tariff right if you go too low people
aren't gonna move I guess a ya know not
enough not enough to make me want to
install solar if the feed-in tariff is
too high you're gonna get this massive
onrush of people coming to install solar
and and now you're gonna have to finance
it right and and and the money has to
come from somewhere in Germany the money
comes from the ratepayers not from the
state what means that if you install
solar panels in your house all of us
have to help pay for the electricity
that you sell back to the grid so our
rate goes up from 18 cents per kilowatt
hour to say eighteen point two cents per
kilowatt hour and then the beginning we
don't notice it
but then if Jo starts putting solar
panels up as well and then let's say 50%
of us put solar panels up now obviously
we're paying a lot more and it gives a
more of an incentive for our people to
put the solar panel up on the roof and
of course the price goes up so the
feed-in tariff is a very it is a market
driven incentive and hence it is very
skillful at rewarding the most efficient
installations but from a government
point of view it requires very
structured rigorous and deft
manipulation of the feed-in tariff rate
the decline of the rate versus time to
ensure that a the installers aren't
reaping an enormous profit and B that
there's that the system doesn't become
unsustainable over time that the burden
on on the ratepayers is not so great
that they're shouldered in for 20 years
paying these excessively high rates so
it rewards first adopters it allows the
markets who predict the the vs. rate of
growth what the reward rate will be and
it allows you to glide into grid parity
all right so we're at a situation today
where we're not at grid parity in in 10
20 years we're likely to be there and so
the regret of the the declining rate of
the feed-in tariff allows you to kind of
glide back in in the United States the
tax rebate unfortunately because of the
way our political system works it tends
to get renewed in a very frequent rate
every two years it seems it's going up
for debate and discussion should we
continue it should we not continue it it
becomes a big political struggle just to
get it passed and as a result everybody
uses up their energy trying to pass this
thing and renew it as opposed to saying
gee what's the best way to decrease this
over time so that we can kind of glide
into grid parity so we have some issues
in the US more related to how our
political system doesn't work but there
are examples of this throughout the
world in terms of what our states and
countries doing to enhance the margins
to create market pull incentives right
to allow solar to be installed on the
grid and the panels that are installed
could come from any
right they could be produced in in in
Guam and and they could qualify for for
the feed-in tariff so it doesn't
discriminate against particular regions
of the world another thing to add here
another thing to add is that this is
just the support from the state from the
public sector from the private sector
what is possible well what is possible
is what's called a power purchase
agreement and this was alluded to during
our tour right what is a power purchase
agreement a power purchase agreement is
instead of instead of you buying a
system and putting it up on your roof
and having to pay all that money upfront
what you do is you enter an agreement
with the Installer they will put the
panels up on your roof for free because
they're getting the financing say from
Morgan Stanley from the Bank of Joe so
the bank of Joe is is is financing the
panels on your roof
so the panels went up on your roof you
didn't pay a penny but you inked an
agreement with me the Installer cuz I
just borrowed money from Joe at a
certain interest rate and you inked an
agreement with me that you'll pay a
certain amount for your electricity over
the next 10 15 20 years however long it
is usually 12 and that rate may be a
little bit higher than what it is today
but it's certainly going to be lower if
current price inflation and continues
for the price of electricity will
certainly be lower than what the price
of electricity will be in 12 years and
so you'll make money I'll make money
because there's a spread between the
rate at which I'm borrowing the money
from the bank and what you're paying for
those panels right for renting the
panels on the roof if you will for
buying the electricity from those panels
so everybody's making money and the
bank's making money obviously because
they're charging an interest rate on the
loan and so with those financing schemes
right where it's called a power purchase
agreement bank loans the money for the
Installer the Installer loans the panels
on the roof of the customer and the
customer phase a pays a fixed price for
the lectricity that allows everybody to
make money from day one as long as
there's capital and play it requires
capital to be in play meaning it
requires the bank of Joe to be willing
to lend money to meet the Installer if
the bank of Joe doesn't want to lend
then that isn't an option
and so you see many of these very large
deels being forged with the investment
banks between large installers say
SunPower SunEdison and so forth and in
new york city it's becoming an
increasingly popular form of financing
solar panels you may stand to make more
money as an individual by buying the
panel's upfront because then you reap
the entire benefit of your investment
you're not sharing the investment
benefit with the Installer you're not
sharing the investment benefit with the
bank but that requires again access to
capital and not everybody has a spare
fourteen fifteen thousand dollars lying
around to put solar on the roof question
yeah so over the past ten years say from
2000 to 2009 in the state of
Massachusetts the price of electricity
increased by 15% so if you compare what
what does it take for a per kilowatt
hour at the beginning and the end
normalized for inflation 15% inflation
in the price of electricity and the
variety of reasons for that
we're at the end of a natural gas
pipeline so even if the price of natural
gas goes down it takes a lot to get it
to us sometimes shipments go in by boat
other times up the actual pipeline
itself and then other forms of fossil
fuel oil especially has experienced a
rise in prices over the last few years
and so for a variety of reasons
including those and including difficulty
in transmission and including limited
new power plants coming online the price
has gone up and as a result if you
project forward you could say okay let's
let's hedge our bets here we can
estimate that the price is going to go
up another 15 percent between now and
the next decade so what I'm gonna do is
say this is the price today this is the
price tomorrow in ten years right I'm
going to sell you electricity here and
so it's it's almost like the deal I
don't know if anybody buddy signs up for
the natural gas lock-in price during
winter with NSTAR you probably receive
the envelope in the mail or maybe your
landlord does but NSTAR the utility
company around this area will allow you
to lock in a price for national gas per
therm per unit of natural gas over the
winter that is slightly above the market
rate in the fall with the understanding
that prices tend to spike during winter
and you're able to hedge you're able to
reduce risk and so really what it is is
a risk mitigation strategy and it's good
enough for most people I know two people
on our street alone have entered Power
Purchase Agreements as means of
financing their solar installations so
let's let's discriminate once again
between the the private sector that's
trying to sell you the panels say home
art you have to buy my panels let me
sweeten the deal here you don't have to
pay a penny upfront we'll
reduce the power purchase agreement
versus what the state is doing right
whether that's the the national
government or the state level is doing
to try to get the installers and other
industries growing within there with an
organization and as well
several the EU states meeting their
Kyoto Protocol obligations to reduce
carbon emissions by a certain amount by
by 2020 so we're gonna do a deep dive
into the German case just because it is
so interesting and so exemplary as in
terms of driving or increasing the
amount of PV on the grid and one thing
to note just upfront this is the
installation map of Europe insulation
being the solar irradiance the total
solar resource available shown in this
barely distinguishable a little legend
down here blue being low red being high
and Germany is right here as they would
say from health Senoia walk by the from
the heart of Europe right there right in
the middle and this is the insulation
comparison again between Germany and
United States same scale over here a lot
less solar resource in Germany even and
then in the north eastern part of the
United States yet there was about half
of all solar panels installed here last
year why well first office high
electricity prices secondly there is a
feed-in tariff that gives an incentive
for solar to be installed in the grid so
I'm going to do is go for several slides
coming from the from a ministry in
Germany describing the growth of solar
and the growth of other renewables on
the grid in response to this feed-in
tariff so the renewable energy resources
if you will as a share of the total
energy supply in Germany the goal by
2020 is this white bar right here and if
we look at the share of renewable
sources in total gross electricity
consumption you can see that it's it's
getting there right 17% versus a minimum
of 35 so working toward their targets
pretty well and climbing from 2000 to
2010 more than doubling almost tripling
this is the electricity heat supply and
fuel supply breakdown if we just look at
the electricity component right here
since that's where PV Falls and and and
contributes you can see it's growing
this again what you have to keep in mind
is the 17% of electricity consumption
coming from renewables the 17% is this
amount here the yellow bar and we're
looking at something in the range of 103
terawatt-hours over the course of a year
in 2010 and out of those hundred and
three terawatt-hours breaking it out
into pv biomass hydro and wind you can
see that pv is accounted for a
relatively small fraction of that total
the the largest by far has been wind
wind reached or has reached the lower
prices of electricity faster than then
solar house differences between the
technology shall we say and as a result
the grid penetration of wind has
preceded that of solar but solar is
growing quite a bit and this is averaged
over the entire country and as I
mentioned before there are certain
regions within Germany as you might
guess down here for instance right that
have experienced larger grid penetration
of solar than others just because they
have a larger solar resource available
to them so so this is the little
fraction here growing of solar
electricity these here are the different
legislations that are being passed
regulating the feed-in tariffs now the
feed-in tariff is scheduled to reduce
gradually for each year let me show you
how that works we'll go back to this
German energy blog by two of our energy
law experts in Germany and this
describes for you the German feed-in
tariffs as of 2010 the renewable energy
sources Act essentially one of those
legislations that have passed and it
just shows you what you can expect over
a variety of different sectors hydro
landfill gas and you can see it's broken
two very specific details different
sizes of installations different types
of plants and so forth this is bio
geothermal onshore wind offshore wind
solar radiation roof-mounted facilities
electricity produced used within the
building facility freestanding
facilities and digression
this means digression means how much
does it go down per year this is based
on their best estimate for the growth of
grid penetration of PV they're trying to
guess in the future how much PV is going
to come on to the grid by a certain date
and hence what the price will be as well
and thus reduce their feet in tariff
accordingly and since it's impossible to
look into a crystal ball and nail it
right especially since this is a
nonlinear system the price depends on
the feed-in tariff the feed-in tariff
depends on the price right so there's a
little bit of that interaction going on
they have to reassess from time to time
what the new rates are going to be and
that's why you have these various well
aside from the initial you have these
various re-evaluations from time to time
looking at the feed-in tariffs now what
has happened more recently there was a
revaluation in January 2009 another mid
2010 right that decreased it even
further so more recently this is
unfortunately only goes to 2010 but more
recently there have been more
significant stronger cuts to the feed-in
tariff in Germany in response to a few
things so let me go over this real quick
I'll get back to that in a second
first off this is the payment of fees in
millions of euros versus time right that
the rate payers are paying in total so
that winds up being something in the
order of a hundred and thirty five euros
per head in Germany and that's not
spread equally amongst everybody per
year that's not spread equally amongst
everybody that's as well their industry
bears more obviously the residential
customer would but it's a line item of a
few euros on your utility bill per month
as a customer and that begins to add up
so Germany has begun putting on the
brakes on the incentives
and further if they look at how much
they've installed versus other countries
again this is the same chart we showed
last class their portion of all new
installations is very large and so they
begin looking around to the rest of the
world saying hey folks we don't have a
lot of Sun here why aren't you doing
your part to to put solar on your grids
compounded by the fact that now they
have a growing percentage of
manufacturing that's not in Germany
right the German the percentage of
German manufacturing of the PV modules
themselves has stayed more or less flat
and so Germany sitting here thinking ok
we're in a financial crisis right now
something has to give
let's put a damper on this feed-in
tariff for a little bit until and until
the the situation straightens itself out
and until there's more growth in other
markets besides just Germany let's try
to reduce the incentive that we give to
put a PV on our grid and maybe increase
the share of PV going on to US China and
so forth other big markets around the
world so that we're not bearing the sole
burden of trying to reduce the cost of
PV to grid parity and as a result the as
a result of this the decline in the
feed-in tariffs in Germany and as a
result of a massive amount of new
production capacity coming online in
China and Taiwan
we're now in an oversupply condition
what means an oversupply condition what
it means is that there is more there are
more PV modules available today than
there are customers to buy them at the
given prices that are available and the
prices dictated in part by the feed-in
tariffs and so what you've seen is so
I'm just going to drive through these
slides whatever here until I get to that
one so what you see is that chart that
secretary Chu presented yesterday during
his talk right this was in first quarter
of 2008 this is when the market began
softening right around here the the
German feed-in tariffs really started
going down tremendously Chinese
manufacturing and Taiwanese
manufacturing really started ramping up
around here 2007 2008 and so what
happened this here is price
not cost price alright so this is being
driven by market dynamics not by not
solely by the cost of manufacturing so
we have what people are willing to pay
for their dollars a lot so if the
feed-in tariff is going down in Germany
which is acquiring 50% of the modules in
the market that means that the price has
to come down as well if you're gonna be
able to sell your modules you're gonna
have to sell them at a lower price
because the feed-in tariff is now lower
at the same time you have now more
supply on the market and you have
companies competing against each other
to get their modules out in the market
and so prices are gonna come down by
that as well so what this chart is
telling you let's look at the blues for
instance let's start here these are
estimates made in 2008 and this blue
line extending forward is the estimated
price not cost the estimated price of
what a PV module would sell for
projected forward to the end of 2010
then we enter 2009 the Reds here and the
prices the real prices continue to drop
precipitously again here we have the
analysts estimates for what the the
price is going to be moving forward to
mm and of 2011 and you can see that the
analysts estimates are always above the
actual prices over the last three years
which means that the prices actual
prices have fallen faster than anybody
or the analysts expected to maybe there
are some smart people among in the in
the actual industry who saw this coming
in quite the same way but what this
means is the prices have come down a lot
faster than what people expected I don't
think people expected that Germany would
cut the feed-in tariff rate quite as as
large as it did in oh 9 and 10 and some
people who haven't been paying attention
to the market might not have expected as
much supply to be available from China
as there is today those people should
have been paying better attention but
that combination of factors resulted in
a much faster price decline than what
people saw coming
and as a result companies that were
formed in say 2007 2008 and got venture
capital and saw one of these lines right
here and said oh we're gonna be able to
intersect them in two
ten are now looking at these sorts of
prices here right and saying oh gee
we're not going to be able to intersect
in the 2010s could be more like 2015
before we get our production costs low
enough to compete at those prices and so
the venture capitalists are now sitting
back thinking so let me get this
straight you came to us three years ago
and told us that you'd be
cost-competitive by 2010 but now the
story is you're gonna be
cost-competitive by 2015 this kind of
smells fishy I don't know if I want to
lend you an additional round here
especially if I have to wait another
five years before you're profitable let
me just cut my losses and and pick up
shop and leave and your company will go
under and so that's happened a few times
that's happened in a high-profile way
which we all know about Solyndra it's
also happened a few other companies
spectra watt even earlier once at the
beginning of the financial crisis opti
Sol and others so the companies that are
surviving right now they're still more
than 100 startup companies in the United
States dozens and dozens of startup
companies in solar those smart ones that
are surviving are are usually in
pre-production stage right so they don't
have big manufacturing lines hundreds
thousands of people to pay supply chains
to pay for and customers evaporating so
they're not caught in that situation
that was Solyndra they had a big
production line they had a thousand one
hundred people employed in that line and
they had customers lined up they had
suppliers shipping in materials that
they were converting into product and
some of the customers disappearing or
not willing to pay as high prices
anymore and that leads to a very
difficult situation you don't have a
cash cushion you can't you don't have
any reserves in the bank you have to
sell your product and you're not able to
compete at these prices it's a recipe
for disaster if you're a mid-sized
company so small companies can survive
in what I call spore mode meaning
they're they're like a spore they don't
have that big manufacturing line to pay
for they can survive off grants they can
survive off at your capital and their
cash burn rate is very low they're
developing technologies the big
companies have cash cushions already
they have cash freezers
so they might even be able to access low
interest rate loans from from banks that
that borrow money at ridiculously low
rates from the Treasury right now they
may even have financial branches within
their own company like GE finance that
can do that sort of thing but so the big
big companies are so far surviving the
really tiny companies are so far
surviving but the market dynamic is
really hitting those midsize companies
that already have a manufacturing line
and so you hear about layoffs you hear
about job losses these are often the
mid-sized companies just trying to enter
go back to spore mode so they can
survive this difficult period until
prices equilibrated and when we look at
prices equilibrating these are these
let's let's look at the price now we're
headed towards q4 2011 let's put a data
point right here for q4 2011 let's do it
right now so I'll go back to here and
sorry about that
that was me registering a website that's
for the project that Doug was working on
we'll go to PV insights and we're gonna
add the latest data point here so solar
wafer this is silicon this is wafer this
is cell and this is module all right so
this is our low this is our high these
are all prices in dollars for what peak
prices are low in our high and our
average for I guess last update was
yesterday the low I can tell you this
this particularly low number right here
came from a Tier three manufacturer in
China
what is tier 1 tier 2 C 3 so tier 1 are
brand names Yingli they advertise during
the World Cup right
Suntech mentioned in secretary Chu's
presentation yesterday Trina Solar ldk
and so forth these are Tier one
manufacturers the big the big dawgs Tier
three are companies you've never heard
of but are employing thousands of people
and manufacturing modules in the
hundreds of bengal ops range perhaps
even reaching a gigawatt scale and
because banks have never heard of them
either maybe that's an overstatement but
I'm making a point here they're not as
well-known they're not as reliable from
the bank's perspective right
maybe they haven't been around as long
as questionable whether they're going to
survive this difficult economic climate
they have difficulty to sell their
product the installers don't want to
take their product and so they have to
undercut the competition they have to
sell they have to leave money on the
table and selling at prices at point $75
per watt
now what Doug's calculations are
indicating is you saw from the very
beginning that the the cost of
manufacturing in the u.s. is around 130
the cost of manufacturing in China is
around $1 and then you have to ship it
over to the US so if if somebody is
willing to sell you a module at point
$75 per watt that means that the price
is below the cost that means that that
company is desperate to get rid of
inventory they must have module stacking
up and they're in their shipment yard
and they're unable to move them and so
the the chief financial officer walks
over and says we gotta get rid of this
stuff it's costing us money it costs us
money to keep this product on the books
sell it for whatever you have to sell it
for to get rid of it and as a
consequence they sell below cost put it
out into the market and then and then
you have solarworld or US company coming
to the Department of Commerce saying
they're dumping product it's an unfair
competition according to the World Trade
Organization you can't sell at a price
below your cost in order to squeeze out
in in gain market share so it's a really
it's a complex situation right now I've
described for you in as much detail as I
can my impression of what's happening in
the world today this low price right
here of 1.75 from a Chinese Tier three
manufacturer and the high price here
coming from most likely a German
supplier or u.s. supplier selling of
what is known to be a very high quality
reputable product has been selling for
the last 10 years very reliable very few
incidences of consumers returning the
product and banks like that product so
they're willing they're able to extract
a premium for their product are able to
sell and move those modules at a higher
price because they're more bankable this
average right here is more
representative of what China
tier-one manufacturers are currently
selling for and what many of the US and
European say average module makers are
having to compete against with costs on
the order of a dollar 30 that's that's
the the constriction right now so if we
add that one data point on to this chart
right here where we have q4 2011 or
solidly in q4 right now and we're at
0.98 with a narrow bar somewhere on here
right so our point 98 see that prices
are still coming down and will likely
come down for maybe another quarter
before they start to stabilize and as
companies fail as more companies leave
the market you'll have consolidation of
market share you'll have the few
remaining companies I have the large
cash cushion that had the lowest cost
structure survive and increase their
market share and reduce the number of
players out in the market and probably
prices will come back up afterwards
because you can't continue selling below
cost for very long before you everybody
goes out of business so I hand going up
over there
so these right here I know that the 0.75
that was an offer price yeah
so the the it was 0.85 during solar
power international at in in in Texas
about a month ago and it made a big
splash and everybody was was it was
really odd by it the point seven five is
news to me probably came up over the
last week or so and in response most
likely to that that companies selling at
0.85 unable to move their product going
even lower in a desperate attempt just
to get rid of their inventory
so these prices most likely are coming
from a few different routes so you can
you as an individual can send an email
or fax over a request for a quote from
any one of a hundred module
manufacturers around the world and you
will get a quote back or an offer sheet
back and most likely what what PB
insights is doing is some combination of
that kind of a guerrilla tactics gather
information and as well information
gleaned from their installer base so
they have contacts to various installer
companies they keep the finger on the
pulse over there talking to their
friends saying how much how much are
they offering you the modules for yeah
the ad the cell and the buy price are a
little different no or currency exchange
markets no this is some these are
individual companies trying to assess
what the market is willing to pay for
their product in the case on the low end
these are desperate customers trying to
move our decimal desperate producers
trying to move product and in the high
end these are these are companies with
high cost structures typically in the
West
typically US and in Germany that have a
reputation and they're clinging for as
long as they can onto the high prices
for as long as they can do it before the
market finally says you know what I'm
sorry we've been good friends we work
together for the last ten years but
honestly I'm not gonna buy it one forty
five not when Suntech is offering me a
module at a dollar five and it's
comparable in quality they've proven
themselves the game that the days when
Chinese modules all Chinese modules were
inferior are over now we have several
tier one Chinese manufacturers that have
proven their modules out in the open
market there haven't hasn't been a large
number of recalls so I'm willing to take
the risk with them and at that point
you'll start to see the the higher
priced US and European products begin to
soften yeah
well keep in mind that this is just the
module there's a whole nother dynamic
happening on the installation side and
the reason I'm not getting into that in
too much detail is because it vary so
much from country to country oh they
will say a few comments before the end
of class
if the oversupply condition continues
and if the feed-in tariffs continue to
be low what you'll see is a continued
softening of the module price into the
point where almost all manufacturers are
selling below manufacturing costs
they're all desperately trying to reduce
manufacturing costs reduce overhead is
forcing them to innovate at least on
manufacturing innovation faster not on
product innovation not on how do we
design the sell differently but more on
the process innovation on the line of
saying gee how do we mix the silver with
the cheaper metal like aluminum in a
ratio so that we we say we eat out half
a cent per watt-peak because any small
fraction counts at this point is it
we're desperate and it's it's really you
you can think of this oversupply
condition as a bunch of horses running
nose to nose and and which ones will
begin falling out in the beginning you
could point to easy candidates those who
have already begun to go by the wayside
but now air companies are burning
through their cash cushion reporting
negative profits you see right and left
even the Chinese Tier one manufacturers
are reporting negative earnings these
this last quarter so that's a reflection
not only if the oversupply condition but
also the fact that they're continuing to
expand
despite the oversupply condition the
idea being well we can withstand one two
three four quarters of losses as long as
we consolidate market share once we
emerge from this oversupply condition
we'll be able to increase prices a bit
more and then return to a more
sustainable market but we'll be the big
dogs and everyone else will be out so I
think all companies right now are trying
to play that game of survive survive
this oversupply condition make it
through some are able to continue
growing and other ones are just stagnant
so the stagnant ones are going to become
niche players they won't be the major
players in the market the ones who
continue growing will be the eighty
ninety percent of the market
so us doesn't do many feed-in-tariffs
this goes back to the u.s. case right
here so due to lack of leadership at the
national level there are a variety of
state-level incentives put forth right
so these are the policies we kind of
talked about this last class but to dive
into a bit more detail the rebate
programs for the renewables these are
state programs plus the utility and/or
nonprofit programs utility local and/or
nonprofit programs only in-state
programs only and so you see for example
in the state of Massachusetts we have
what used to be the the Massachusetts
technology collaborative there was a bit
of a power struggle within a state and
it got incorporated into a more
centralized organization downtown the so
that used to be a nonprofit organization
which is now more affiliated with the
state the state also has a rebate we
have a very different set of ways of
doing things and say California which
has the Clean Energy Commission that
rates each module and gives you a rebate
depending on what they rate the module
as performing in California so every
state is when we have tweaked things and
it becomes very complicated very quickly
to enact a national incentive beyond the
tax rebate that is already offered today
is is challenging in this political
climate especially because anything that
you would do to raise the cost of
something which most likely would come
from some federal program right now the
Republican Party is demanding that there
be an offset a reduction in spending
elsewhere within the government and many
of the discretion when either the places
that are easy to cut have already been
cut right and so you've gone through the
fad you're now hitting muscle and pretty
soon you're going to be hitting bone so
it's difficult to enact something that
the government would pay for it is even
more difficult to enact something that
the utilities and rate payers would pay
for at a national level because
oftentimes those powers are delegated to
the states and you would enter a big a
federal versus state fight over that
which would go to the courts most likely
and be held up there for several years
there are about 18,000 different
independent jurisdictions within the
United States governing how Soler's is
added to the grid and so at the
Department of Energy has done which I
think is the wisest thing to do and
given this situation that we have is to
say okay we're not going to force
anybody to change but we're going to
give an incentive for people to change
and like they had in the Department of
Education a race to the top where states
competed against each other to implement
best practices in education they're
having a similar program on the
installation side of solar trying to get
various states to adopt the best
practices to streamline the permitting
process to get solar onto the grid in
the most efficient way possible and
hopefully reduce the installation costs
associated with that so let's let's turn
our attention quickly to installations
and say I want to give some time to have
people ask questions about their class
projects since time is running very
short if you're hitting up against a
roadblock I want to make sure that we
resolve that I'll say a couple of words
about the installation so if anything
happened on Tuesday night I met with a
colleague from Wisconsin and he said
well I met the editor of I think it was
an editor from one of the big journals
will protect the innocent and this was a
very high impact journal scientific
journal and he said well the majority of
the cost right now is in the
installation side not in the module in
solar so I'm not going to be interested
in any papers to my journal that
described new concepts for PV modules
I'm interested in the installation side
because that's where the majority of it
cost us I don't know my goodness here's
another one who can't distinguish
between cost and price so the
installation cost right now let's focus
on cost first and then we'll get to
price so the installation costs in the
United States is partially reflective of
the fact that we have those 18,000
different ways of doing it here versus
in Germany there is one way to do it
nationally the federal government said
we are going to 'men demand that
everybody in Germany install in this
protocol and the paperwork is very very
brief it's a couple of pages to get it
installed the inspection is one and so
Germany has a much more efficient system
and they've installed roughly six to
seven times more solar than we have and
if you remember experience learning
curves with when you have the reduction
of cost the more you do it that means
you have three doublings Germany has
three doublings over us and even if you
assume a very leisurely 20% reduction
for each doubling that means Germany is
about the half of the cost as we are
because they've done it more they know
how to do it more efficiently than we do
okay so that's that's on the cost side
on the price side on the price side if
you look around the u.s. you have some
states like New Jersey which had an
amazing incentive program for a while
and California's as well quite generous
so there are certain states where it's
almost like a gold mine and so there's
no incentive for the Installer to reduce
their price their costs can be going
down but their price can be maintained
high and usually this isn't always the
case but in most industries when prices
are high the industry becomes lazy now
this isn't always the case but it is
often the case it is not a typical that
when the prices are high the industry
says Oh prices are high that's pretty
good I'm enjoying myself right now I'm
not going to be focused on cost
reduction it seems that at least the the
lower level managers suddenly become
fixated on cost reduction when it's too
late right when when margins have
already been shrinking when prices are
collapsing and when it's do-or-die for
the company then then all of a sudden
costs becomes imperative so there are
very few companies the ones that usually
become leaders are the ones who
recognize the costs can't or prices
can't remain high forever we have to
reduce our costs now and and hey it'll
it'll be even to our benefit because our
margins will be greater we'll be able to
take advantage of this right now and
build up some cash so that when the
prices do collapse we have we have some
buffer and we can survive the the
oversupply condition so installers right
now I have to say in disappointment in
in our installers in the United States
for not doing more amongst themselves to
reduce the amount of paperwork to for
not taking leadership role in reducing
the paperwork burden and the true cost
of installing PV on the
so some Kaizen installation site I think
that's a very resolvable problem you
look to Germany and you have residential
systems going in for below three euros
per watt-peak price taking advantage of
the low module prices right now and the
fact that the installation costs in
Germany are low as well so because
they've learned how to do it well
they've learned how to do it efficiently
and they've reduced their cost structure
so I personally I think there is
innovation to be done on the
installation side I think there's a lot
that can be done with prefabrication
maybe moving a robot out there that can
assemble things in a big rack and in the
crane that puts it on the roof as
opposed to having ten people going out
to a house and spending a couple days
putting panels on the roof it's not that
bad maybe it's more like a day but it's
still a very labor intensive industry
right now in the US so more innovation
can be done but the lion's share the
lion's share of the installation price
right now is driven by what I would call
just inefficiencies in the way
installation is done and inefficiencies
in the way the permitting process is
done the paperwork is done so that's my
soapbox speech on installation by all
means there is innovation to be done so
don't don't don't give up on that side
either it's important it's where the
rubber hits the road but I think it's
not you can't just look at the the price
of modules today and the price of
installing the system today in the
United States and realize that 80% of
the price right now is wrapped up in the
installation and say oh well there isn't
any more innovation to be done in module
side you have to look at cost and you
have to recognize that the module cost
is driven by the efficiency of the
module and the installation costs as
well will be driven by the efficiency of
the module and so the module being the
engine of the system is still very very
very important and so the work that
folks are doing on new PV materials
especially is is is important
you